hey there's a petition to uh require  hot dogs and buns yeah they'd be sold in  equally sized packages  and it's gaining steam online right  aren't you mad about that  ketchup and mustard maker hines is  behind this  it already has over 10 000 signatures  it calls on the bun and hot dog  industries to find the answer to the  mismatched packaging it's one of those  things that never made sense i know  you get ten buns but only eight dogs  wait what is the challenge of finding  the answer it's just  either two more complicated yeah it's  addition and subtraction  remedial math you can do it hot dog  industry  together teamwork makes the dream work